México despide al Amigo de todos los
niños el actor y conductor mexicano
Javier López Rodríguez falleció el
sábado a los 88 años de edad es un día
muy muy muy triste para nosotros para
mucha gente su doctor de cabecera el
Doctor Carlos Soto lo Atendió y ahí se
descubrió que el problema no era
pulmonar ni respiratorio sino abdominal
presentando un cuadro de abdomen agudo y
más adelante un choque séptico
que le quitó la vida
[Música]
el 26 de noviembre de 1967 se estrenó En
familia con Chabelo un programa que
estuvo casi medio siglo al aire y rompió
récords en la televisión mexicana
ha pedido a Santa Claus Javier
interpretado al personaje por el que
será recordado para siempre un niño de
voz aguda y pantalones cortos que con Su
carisma cautivaba a las familias
mexicanas pese a sus 192 metros de
estatura Chabelo logró conquistar el
corazón de los mexicanos pese a no haber
nacido en México nació el 17 de febrero
de 1935 en Chicago Estados Unidos
siempre conservó la nacionalidad de
estadounidense y hasta prestó servicio
militar allí empezó la carrera de
Medicina pero la dejó para trabajar como
ayudante en un programa de televisión y
ahí nació el niño Chabelo Televisa
informó que retransmitirá el programa En
familia con Chabelo y películas del
actor Javier López Rodríguez y hasta el
presidente dio sus condolencias abrazo a
familiares y amigos por el fallecimiento
de Javier López Chabelo Cómo olvidar que
mi hijo mayor se despertaba temprano
para verlo hace más de 40 años su
familia pidió privacidad para despedirlo